difference so ccsd they may have that
pause on classes right now
but for now at least unlv is full speed
ahead with in-person classes thousands
getting ready to kick off the semester
here in just a few days question is are
in-person classes safe our hector mia
joining us live on campus with what the
university has to say hector good
morning
good morning and the university here
says in-person learning is safe as long
as everyone follows the safety protocols
that are in place in fact they're
offering sixty percent of the classes in
person the rest offered online and as we
talk about the return to class in the
spotlight vaccinations two weeks ago the
board of regents voted to keep the
vaccine mandate in place for staff more
than 96 percent of unlv staff are fully
vaccinated nevada system of higher
education employees who refused to get
the vaccine or did not have an approved
exemption had until december 31st or get
fired tomorrow the board will revisit
the mandate for the students unlv says
more than 90 percent of the students
will be vaccinated when the spring
semester starts
we still do offer testing through our
on-campus clinic for faculty and
students and so we think in the coming
weeks testing the pressure on that will
diminish and it will be much easier to
get tests
free testing for the community moved
from unlv to sam boyd stadium due to the
high demand the southern nevada health
district is opening additional
facilities around the valley and with
the pandemic far from over the president
here at unlv sent a letter to staff
members as they all get ready for a new
semester reminding them to keep and to
carry on with the safety protocols
including mask wearing which is required
indoors reporting live hector mejia live
local now